is here this is the house we've got
second little bit one for him
which could be maybe dad on a table and
which is a brand new kitchen and then
communal kitchen shower in here big
bathroom
so this is good and now this is really
gonna be an integration because this
room is tiny so you would not be able to
rent this out as a room is probably
about 50 square feet however we've got
here oh sorry a really nice bathroom
which has been fitted quite recently
unfortunately what we'd have to do if
we're gonna have to turn this bathroom
into part of the bedroom by simply
knocking this wall out which gives us a
fourth double bedroom so altogether
we've got a house right Hannah Senter
yeah how many people are looking at how
much do you think from looking at the
tenants oh look into the properties what
do you think we'll get per room here so
we saw 3 1950 yeah we're being
conservative working on 3 to 5 yes which
means that we'll be getting rent all
about 1,200 1,300 pounds per month and
tell us how much of you agreed pounds
I'm relieved it's been great we see
different houses put an offer in a house
it's great you can't learn isn't
classroom do it guys you want to see us
view and buy more houses in real life
like this and don't forget to Like share
and subscribe and the more you do that
the more we will film if you're also
interested in investing yourself and
getting crazy high returns then don't
forget go down to
www.prophecyinthenews.com at UK and we
can help you do that too